- Got a big birthday coming up later,
and it's the big 3-0.
- The big 3-0, Kelly.
- The big 3-0. I love my thirties, yeah.
- Yeah, no, you always
talk about your thirties.
- My twenties were hard.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- What did you-
- Because I was lonely,
I didn't have a band.
(laughing)
It was lonely.
- That's why you're having
so much fun here with this.
- Yeah. I love my band.
I just mean, it's hard like when you're
in the spotlight like that,
that to like, you know
just communicate what that's like.
So, I was, yeah twenties were
hard, but thirties are cool.
You're gonna love it.
- My twenties were fun.
I had a great time.
- Whatever, Niall.
- (laughing) Yeah.
- I was, no, I was having a
great time in my twenties.
I really enjoyed it.
- Do you freak out about age?
Are you freaking out about it?
- No, I'm one of those
people I couldn't care less.
Honestly.
- Me too.
Everybody talks about the thirties
being the new twenties, so I'm up for it.
I feel older, my hangovers are worse.
- (laughing) Harder?
- Jesus, they're very long.
Your knees as well?
- You know, me and the knees.
- I know.
Soccer is hard on you.
- (laughing) Yeah it is.
- But no, I'm looking forward to it.
My best friend, since I
was like three years old,
his parents and my parents were
in the same class at school.
We were in the same class at school.
His name is Mully, and-
- I'm sorry, Mully from Mullingar?
- (laughing)
- His surname is Mulholland,
like the street here.
- (laughing)
So he's got it all going on.
Mullingar, Mulholland.
- I love it.
I love it.
- So he and I-
- I just had to,
it's where they're from.
That's amazing.
(audience laughing)
- She's seen it, I had
a shirt on the other day
with Mullingar written on it.
Kelly was like, "Ah-ha!"
(laughter)
- And then-
- But your friend's name
is Mully, that's great.
- Yeah, and he's like five
weeks, six weeks older than me.
- Okay.
And we're gonna do a joint
30th, because I hate-
- (imitating Irish accent) Thirtieth.
(audience laughing)
- A joint 30th birthday.
- You know, you think they would've
got used to me over here after 13 years?
- Nope.
- 13.
- Still love it.
- (imitating Irish
accent) 13. After 13 years
I still think it's funny.
No, so what are y'all gonna,
you're gonna be doing big joint thing.
- Yeah, well I don't like...
the last time I celebrated
my birthday was 21.
Went to Vegas.
Did the whole...
- Wow. That's fun.
Did the whole deal. That was, whoo.
- Yeah.
- That was big.
And then I haven't
celebrated really since.
I'm not really a birthday guy
but 30th I'm definitely gonna do.
- Really the 30th one.
(speaking in Irish accent)
So...
- Kelly, please.
- I'm gonna keep doing it.
- Geez.
- It's awesome, I love it.
So wait, you don't like cele-
you like just being low key?
- I don't know. I just like,
I'd go for a few drinks
with a few mates or-
- Yeah.
- Make sure that there's no cake.
- That's how I do it. Yeah.
Don't like surprises and-
- I hate surprises.
- Hate them.
- Yeah.
- And I also don't like
the happy birthday-
- Do you feel pressure to have
to be like, "I love this".
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So don't do that.
If you're gonna surprise me.
- I know.
I did hear that you don't like
when people sing Happy Birthday to you.
So I'm totally gonna
get Shelton to do that
for me on video to send
it to your birthday.
- No, I don't mind it. Like,
if it's been sent to me
or whatever, but if, you
know, when you're in a room.
The whole room is looking at you and it's
a 40 second spiel, compliment thing.
- Yeah, don't, doesn't it happen
like every time you end
a song on like the stage.
- Yeah
I guess so.
- Yeah.
- It's a different thing, though.
- Don't, don't you hate when people just
sit there and adore you.
- Because you-
(laughing)
- But you can't just
like, you can't start,
it's not like you can clap along.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's awkward.
- It's not like
you sing along to your own birthday song.
- Yeah, I would.
- Yeah, I know you would.
- And yeah, I've just never been,
I've never been a fan of
the birthday thing, but-
- Okay. Duly noted.
- Yeah.
- Oh, you shouldn't have me.
- Cunning, Cunning Clarkson.
- Well I wanted to ask you
about a lyric from Heaven,
and this is so great y'all.
It goes, "Let's not get complicated.
Let's just enjoy the view.
It's hard to be a human so
much to put an answer to
but that's just what we do."
What inspired that lyric?
I love that.
Yeah.
- It's so good. I guess that heaven kinda
for me, came from like,
just from previous generations.
Society kind of tells us you
need to do this at this age
you need to do that at that age.
Hit all these milestones,
whether it be marriage, kids,
whatever it may be.
- Yeah.
- Have a career at this age.
Do that at that age.
And I was just like, I've
always been one of those,
like I know for the
lack of a better phrase,
"live in the moment" kind of person,
and just kinda like
whatever's in front of you,
just do it and then deal with it-
- Yeah.
- As you go.
So I kind of always had that.
I was just saying it to the
guys when I started singing,
"God only knows where this could go."
I was thinking that's just a life thought.
And I think that's exciting.
- Yeah.
- To not know.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Like, God only knows
where this could go.
I think that's cool.
The opportunity of what
that could be is cool.
- Yeah. I like, I like the,
I don't like surprises,
generally if someone's gonna
come in and surprise me
but I do like surprises in life
and things popping up for good or for bad.
- Absolutely.
- To be honest,
Like if it pops up, you deal
with it and if it's good
you deal with it and...
Yeah, I just, we do-
- Hopefully you learn either way.
- Yeah, either way.
- Yeah.
- That's, that's the idea, I guess.
- Such a great song.
I mean the melody's cool,
the lyrics are awesome.
It's just, I love how the
melodies, there's so many,
there's like a few different
like just major hooks going on.
I love that.
I wanna do another lyric
though, in your first solo,
which I love and it reminds me of like,
I feel like you could have
like grown up in Nashville.
Because this is such a
singer songwriter song.
It's called This Town.
Everybody knows that.
(audience cheering)
So you wrote, you wrote,
"Because if the whole world was watching,
I'd still dance with you."
That's so nice.
"Drive highways and byways
to be there with you,
over and over, the only truth
everything comes back to you."
Ah.
- Yeah.
- Like is there a, do you
have to have a certain muse
or can you just be inspired at the idea?
Like that feels personal, but you might be
one of those people that can write about-
- Yeah.
- "I want that to be"
my situation.
- Oh no, I have no issue
writing about anything.
I'm one of those people
I, I do try and keep...
Like have that as the single thought
and then build a storyline around it.
- Yeah.
- That's what I tend to do.
I'm like, this song was
basically about my hometown
and kind of everything
that I feel about it now
that I've spent time
traveling the world and-
- Away from it, yeah.
- You know what it's like,
when you're there you're
like, "I hate this place."
- "I gotta get out."
- "It's a dump."
"I gotta get out. I hate you, mom."
- Yeah.
- And then you're like,
"Oh, I wanna go home now."
- Yeah.
And I think the older I've gotten,
the more I've wanted to go back.
But yeah, they just, it's,
that's what I've always
like when I write, when
I think of my hometown
it straightaway brings up finger picking
- Yeah.
and Nashville songwriting-
- And folky kind of stuff.
And that's what I naturally
do, when I pick up a guitar
I naturally just like finger pick and-
- Yeah.
- And all that
kind of good stuff.
That's what comes to me.
- It's so natural to me.
Like even our conversations with, you know
Blake and Jans like backstage,
I feel that you are just
like that writing community.
Which is so cool.
- I love-
- Because you love storytelling.
- I love a story.
- Yeah, me too.